attention vous entrez dans un monde sans
mensonge
[Musique]
c'est très gentil de ta part en tout cas
d'invités pour prendre un dernier verre
non mais le dernier verre c'est juste
une technique bon vous semble oui ça
j'avais compris mais moi j'ai prendre un
verre avant de parler une heure ou deux
de connaître moi qui se passe comme ça
moi ça m'arrange pas trop parce que vu
que tu es un peu crevé je te cache pas
qu'on va pas parler parler à temps 1
qu'est ce tu fait pour que tu m'enlèves
mais parce que ce serait ça c'est dit
mais non mais c'est pas sexy ça fait
juste mal je saigne
pourquoi dans le film c'est toujours
beau et on dirait deux joueurs tennis
qui retient leur survêt par situer
m'excite faudrait arrêter de parler
n'est pas raison et vous allez a été
vachement mieux qu'on aime ça c'est en
fait si je prends une photo pour mes
copains est non je préfère pas en fait
parce que si je te donne plus nouvelle
après tu vas tu mangeais durée matière
internet tu penses
non j'en prendrai une quand tu dormiras
discret tous les maires ah bon j'ai fait
mon maximum j'ai tout donné sa clio
bombardons métro voilà qu'est ce que
t'es moche quand tu joues je me suis
jamais vu ça casse et apoula fini à
temps je pourrai rentrer à côté du métro
jaurès pas dormir tu te sentirais trop
collant ça attire ouais je comprends que
non parce que je vais faire c'est quand
tu seras parti j'avais un petit sms pour
dire que j'ai passé un très bon moment
et que quand on fait ça quand tu es ok
vous devez prendre tout mon temps pour
répondre juste pour te montrer cassama
qu'ils contrôlent je dois aller j'ai
fait comme si j'avais entendu
[Musique]